welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and where the hell was qui-gon jinn
the entire time obi-wan needed him and
his long bearded guidance huh like why
did you wait to the very end of the
season after obi-wan got his ass dragged
in the sand by your supposedly chosen
one to show up huh well i personally
think that this makes perfect sense
actually and is very much in line with
what has been established in previous
star wars canon and i'm about to tell
you why my nerd babies but first let me
tell you why you need to pick up our
newest latest obsession shirt inspired
by obi-wan kenobi and the reason why the
show is over so this latest obsession
shirt is about to disappear into the
cosmic force so be sure to pick up one
of our latest obi-wan kenobi shirts or
our newest miss marvel shirts inspired
by miss marvel really dope shirts always
over at new rockstarsmerch.com pick one
up today alright so the reason why i
believe obi-wan kenobi could not see the
force ghost of his former master qui-gon
jinn was because by living in isolation
and not trusting a single damn soul that
wasn't a space camo obi-wan kenobi cut
himself off from the very source of the
force that qui-gon jinn's force ghost is
now directly tied to the living force a
crucial part of the force that qui-gon
jinn loved talking about back in his day
when he was alive like what is this term
living force anyway well yoda had that
question at one point too but lucky for
him the voice of qui-gon jinn from
beyond the grave gave yoda an explainer
in episode 11 of season six of clone
wars a force that consists of two parts
living beings generate the living force
which in turn powers the wellspring that
is the cosmic force all energy from the
living force
from all things that have ever lived
feeds into the cosmic force binding
everything and communicating to us
through the midichlorians
because of this i can speak to you now
before he died qui-gon jinn learned the
force is actually comprised of two
symbiotic parts the cosmic force and the
living force and the living force is
what lives in every single living being
in the galaxy and it's this energy field
that the jedi and sith manipulate for
their own purposes like it is the
invisible energy of life itself that is
given to all four sensitives regardless
of religious affiliation through the
little microscopic sentient and
intelligent organisms that live in the
cells of every living being throughout
the galaxy called midichlorians now look
i know some of you out there really
don't like the concept of midi-chlorians
but whether you like it or not
midichlorians are actually central to
the entire star wars mythos because like
qui-gon jin said they are responsible
for life itself giving life the energy
it needs to survive and like qui-gon
jinn tells yoda in clone wars
midi-chlorians themselves are born from
the other complementary side of the
force the cosmic force the part of the
force that all living beings in star
wars go when they die and a place that
exists outside of space and time that
binds the universe together so basically
everything that lives eventually dies
and goes into the cosmic force and then
the cosmic force influences the
midichlorians and the midichlorians
create life in the universe basically
like a yin yang situation the living
force flows into the cosmic force and
the cosmic force goes back into the
living force and the cosmic force is
extremely important to star wars because
this is where the will of the force
lives like this is what becoming one
with the force means after you die it's
becoming one with the cosmos and when
your living force energy becomes one
with the cosmic force along with every
other being that has ever died your
living force energy now goes into the
cosmic force helping the cosmos
manipulate the destinies of all the
living people according to the cosmos's
own plan for the universe and star wars
tends to call this cosmic plan for the
universe the will of the force like in
pretty much every piece of star wars
media you hear that the destiny of the
galaxy is guided by the will of the
force and you see that the jedi are
constantly meditating to try to get some
type of magical insight from the cosmos
about what is happening in the galaxy
this is the cosmic force speaking to the
jedi with and this is very important the
help of those very helpful living force
midichlorians in their blood translating
what the cosmic force is saying like
remember that moment from the end of the
rise of skywalker when rey hears all the
voices of the past jedi giving her
encouragement as she stares off into the
stars those jedi died and were one with
the cosmic force and were using rey's
living force midichlorians to produce
the sounds within rey so that rey could
hear them like midichlorians are the
bridge between the dead and the living
and also the bridge between the force
user and the force in general because
the midichlorians give users force
powers so this being said when qui-gon
jinn died in the phantom menace his life
energy that was tied to the living force
transferred over to the cosmic force and
since afterlife force ghost energies of
the cosmic force can only communicate
through living force midichlorians if
one severs one connection to the living
through years of isolation on tatooine
losing all their hope in people more and
more by the day your connection to the
living force midichlorians is going to
be weak as hell because your connection
to the living is non-existent like it
was only through meeting leia and luke
that obi-wan was able to fully restore
his connection to the living force
because princess leia reminded obi-wan
of the value of connecting with the
living and it wasn't until obi-wan freed
himself for being so preoccupied
with thinking about the betrayal of his
dead padawan failure anakin skywalker
and learned that the living can not only
be trusted but also inspire a new hope
for the future that obi-wan was able to
reconnect with the living force
midichlorians within his body which
allowed him to see his old master
qui-gon jinn this is what the main
importance of obi-wan breaking out of
his rocky vader tomb in the finale was
his experience with princess leia gave
him hope for the living and the hope for
life in general and that specific
reawakened connection to life allowed
obi-wan to use his living force
midichlorians to the absolute best of
his abilities which is why we have never
seen obi-wan kenobi so damn strong in
the force before like he lifted so many
rocks and he threw him out darth vader
and vader couldn't do [ __ ] like leia's
love was like rocket fuel for obi-wan's
midi-chlorians and they just ate that
[ __ ] right up so yeah qui-gon jinn was
right he didn't go anywhere qui-gon now
being one with the cosmic force was now
everywhere and always with obi-wan it
was obi-wan himself that needed to
change his receptiveness to the living
in order to restore his connection to
the living force via his living force
midichlorians and it is through the
living force that you can see cosmic
force ghosts like qui-gon jinn and be
attuned to the will of the force in
general but that is why i believe
obi-wan kenobi could not see qui-gon jin
until the very last moment of the finale
but what do you guys think of the finale
in general let us know in the comment
section below and of course you gotta
let us know what you guys think of the
finale because like my god i'm still
thinking about that days later but yeah
thank you guys so much for watching this
video you can follow me mastertainment
on twitter if you want to see me tweet
some weird [ __ ] and some really fun
theories but more importantly you can
follow new rockstars wherever we are on
social media make sure you hit that
notification bell on youtube you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video and of course again hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com to pick up our newest
latest session obi-wan kenobi shirt
because that shirt is going away like
very soon but i love you guys so much
and uh may the force be with you
at star trek goodbye
[Music]
you